how's it going resumes well you made it
welcome back to part two of second son
infamous we left off by sacrificing
myself what's going on
oh we're sleeping
[ __ ] going on in Seattle huh
oh how did that happen what happened
[ __ ] yeah what the hell so is this the
the house we were to put oh god yeah
that looks painful so she did that how
did we make it
that doesn't make any sense
do this did she hurt Oh God this is
books a volume 7 that's my favorite no
could stop her damn that looks painful
as [ __ ] did they just pull them out or
something under stain get loose Oh Betty
dear you're awake so to agustin do this
to you yes did you think I was gonna rat
you out to that one retry besides at the
time it seems like all the cool kids
were giving their legs fierce legs
Peter's only here where comas would
protect our own
we made the right choice here blames you
for what happened yeah neither should
you can't be ashamed for what you are
can't help it you were born that way
it matters I love them now who are not
one of those beady eyed by own community
hide killing people Higley piggley
you're a good boy
just happen to have smoke coming out of
your thing
hey my butt the whole reason why we're
in this is smoke coming off my fingers
hey don't go down that road if you're
gonna be such a buzzkill I mean I have
to go back to sleep cuz I need my rest
so that I can get better and get on my
feet I guess the rest thing is gonna
make those stones come out rest now cuz
you're awake fine really
mm-hm
no that was fast she's just pretending
that will go away
isn't she I do that sometimes
just pretend sleep random leave someone
boring is talking to me it works nine
out of ten times poor Betty her cheeks
are like potatoes lumpy lumpy shoe as'
potatoes the legs glad to see fast
healing seems to be a part of your new
thing speaking of which the craziness
with the hands is that gone there's no
smoking
yeah but can only use the power when
they're smoking you want to get in the
way of anyone's recovery recovery hey
Belson these these people aren't getting
any better they're dying man you don't
know that
no but the doctors who came through here
when you were out they do and they said
that they said the only way those shards
are coming out is the exact same way
they went in that was August steam in
her concrete power we need to steal her
power right this scrutiny looks like you
and me are going to Seattle we're gonna
go get her right wait what you think
you're just gonna charm her into coming
back here with you come on man I know
you took a bump to the head but who
didn't exactly hit it off last time you
were together Reggie I did this and I
gotta fix it no Justin you just got back
on your feet look I know you want to
help but the doctors have already said
the only way it's getting out is with
the same power I get it which means
you don't actually need Augustin we just
need her power power of fab which I
already had are you blind
I'm a goddamn power sponge remember if I
got smoke why can't I get concrete what
if smoke was just a fluke huh
think about you'd have to go through
what I do you pee guys just to get to
work yeah probably something like that
explaining the truck what truck have a
truck I I like I like the characters so
far
I was worried the main character was
gonna be like I got this whole thing
figured too much we hit the town we load
up at the all you can leech conduit
power buffet maybe swing by the space
Neal always wanted to see it and then
we're back home to save some lives
you do realize when we hit the town
there's a fair chance the town's gonna
you know head back what does that even
mean it means that Seattle has half a
million people that aren't exactly
thrilled about the bio terrorists that
are already there you think they're
gonna welcome you know but I'm gonna be
different
okay I'm not they're doing what they do
I'm there to save lives I'm gonna be
like Superman to be healing the sick
hero what you think they're gonna throw
you a parade wake up man I'll be like
Smokey Moses SMO say all right we're
gonna fix this thing I'm gonna find you
a cure a cure
shooting smoke out of your fingertips
isn't exactly normal man not if you're
not normal doesn't mean that it needs a
cure okay van Gogh wasn't normal
Gandhi wasn't no Gandhi all right people
are afraid of bio terrorists they're
freaks that's pre-program wool it's kind
of like x-men red people hate people
with power I guess which is always
interesting
[Music]
looks like blue walking the rest of the
way what what yeah where you going hey I
guess this is what we heard on the news
about Seattle if you're having second
thoughts are you kidding me
this is amazing this is destruction this
is self-defense man the roadblock was
setup to attack them because their bio
terrorists
well it didn't stop them and stop this
bad boy either peace so much peace this
is like a post-apocalyptic Vegas
oh is this smoke this I mean yeah gallon
water his head I have a vision about
shooting lasers now it's most it's Moses
not Jesus as I press r2 to fire a smoke
shot not at you you look expensive
you're not really shooting me Toto the
concrete queen Hey I'm hoping to avoid
that listen there might be another way
that we can get to Agustin have a few
connections in Seattle write some in the
police no no no no no this is not the
point where Reggie swoops in and makes
everything all right this is not your
problem to fix it is mine yeah they're
perfect you want to go help somebody
go save damsel in distress that's not
fine we both go oh no no you go play
Super Cup okay I will catch up with you
in a minute
all right but don't go anywhere and for
God's sake don't touch anything I'm
gonna touch everything everything you're
up first little guy what is this so in
their technologies so they drop these
charts wait I don't have enough about
this drain to smoke all right it's time
to shoot [ __ ] what the [ __ ] there we go
nail that drain it
I love how the controllers making noise
and so on three Adam for our support
Baroness I have to kill it now go Bayon
alright now we have them what is that
dude you will not believe what that
beeping would just tell them to hold on
I'll get the bus unstuck Nelson I know
what you're thinking and don't dude I
just took out a fleet of quad copters I
think I could dig out a bus okay let's
see what we can upgrade first I can't
shoot them right this is gonna take
forever there's got to be a faster way
oh well there you go then it's gonna
show up before it come on cinder blast
yeah yeah yeah it's like a shot shotgun
smoke shot your smock
yep that's the word I made up doesn't
mean is not as gay it'll just hit me
Jesus all right where are we going to
Seattle
she'd be coming around Seattle when she
comes she be coming around Seattle
they're gonna ride this baby straight
into Seattle let's go baby
what's going on here
oh you got it
[Music]
Delsin we got a problem some of the
people on the bus they saw you doing
your super thing to clear the way and
they're afraid of you liked I told you
man bio terrorists aren't especially
popular like Rosa Parks and they want me
so much back no they want you to sit
outside the bus bunch of races they
don't want you in here
right they said if you come on they're
gonna get off we're not gonna do that
these people have never seen anything
like you before and they're scared right
and I can't blame them just give me a
second look just let me run them across
the bridge I'll come right back for you
all right it'll take five minutes
I'm Konya my man I can't let you on the
bus I'm gonna bribe there five minutes
don't let samosas on the bus whatever I
don't care
oh well I probably walk faster anyway
yeah oh you mean like right now Oh
notice that's convenient I didn't know
it had a HUD whoa what is this the
eighties superpower that's awesome I
wish I had that in vain that mean sounds
like useful information the bridge
[Music]
what is going on here what's gonna
happen god damn Oh what how did this
close yo Jesus I would be [ __ ] my
pants a vibe oh I don't know let's try
and sneak up just kidding you did and
kill you for killing me
racist scumbags
[ __ ] how much smoke do I have that
we good
don't run it's no fun then come on let's
suck up some smoke hey chachi yeah we go
no headshots there we go one stop listen
there you go you did one more let's make
him run more fun and they said that was
great give me your cases oh the looter
is trying to surrender press to subdue
or execute for evil we're going with the
good guys and I want to change the world
I want to change how people see us so
we're gonna subdue me we're not all
monsters spread the word I just kicked
his ass that's what I did I'm not an
[ __ ] I swear I just murdered all your
friends but I'm sure you'll spread the
word how amazing I am tiptoein in my
Jordan's planet sorry okay oh oh oh oh
this should be heaven to me this is
great oh my god Jesus I mean smosh's
whoa
yeah
it's beautiful [ __ ] gorgeous this
game man it's really fun to play on the
edge like I said this is the first game
I play on the ps4 is it's really cool so
smooth like Jesus guys the ps3 is so
outdated
new power it's whatever gay superjump
know what is it trying to makes well
then okay why do I have to stand on a
car to do it yeah amazing
that's pretty cool okay look at this who
did all this is cray cray
Oh God okay this is not look safe why do
I have to be on the car again I don't
know don't question it is that a new one
did we get more Jesus like Christmas
here Christmas and birthdates likes
gross I try okay
scratched a quick curve Chris Chris day
I can Christine
hold and jump jump and hold oh oh oh I
always wanted a private jet pack that's
awesome
hello Betty oh no don't worry Betty
quick I promise but kind of in the
middle of something here Betty how about
I call you when I get there okay I call
you later Betty boo love you Betty boo
Oh God Oh God Betty Betty huh okay okay
we're fine
Oh Betty she's so adorable it would be
kind of a funny plot twist if Betty was
the evil girl or some [ __ ] freezing Oh
smoke - wiling Oh
now oh oh oh s--- bridge I knew it
samosas we'll have to cleanse his evil
bridge from the devil it's pretty smooth
I love this jetpack thing or whatever it
is so cool how convenient god oh god did
not mean to do that almost died
conveniently-placed car thank you
[Music]
oh damn can I get up there there we go
so cool that's amazing I always wanted
to do something like this that's awesome
this game is awesome
yep town huge it's been living it
oh [ __ ] oh well that was fast
where's it all the people on the bus oh
I gotta help read you before tales
goddamn you Randy I thought you would
kill got to do all this [ __ ] here there
we go he doesn't want to get whacked
this is worse he's like a hat any kin
brother get out Oh
seem to be getting the hang of your new
symptoms right look what's the only
downside being that nope
can't think of anything this is pretty
freakin classy really no downside I put
those heavily armed guys over there now
want to hurt you real bad
hi-yah now look we're all we know we may
be able to pass you through their
security you know because you're not a
normal final terrorist no no no if you
mean by normal
you know the sheep that they try to line
up so that they can probe them no Reggie
I'm not normally did you see what I did
on that bridge I take these guys just
see if we can sneak you through their
checkpoints first all right it'll make
getting around the city
okay fine you do it your way I'll subtle
God so named all right I'm gonna have to
end this episode here Bruce
hope you enjoyed watching thank you for
liking and commenting on this video and
thank you for hanging out with me today
Bruce I'll see you in the next one as
always stay awesome bros bro